this month with a long weekend on the
horizon and some big seasonal moments
shoppers can find savings across a few
different categories
making it a really great time to commit
to some smart and timely purchases
kirsten joyce joining us live in studio
with a few of the top sales
all right brian discounts on big ticket
electronics not strictly reserved for
black friday february
is the second cheapest time of year to
buy a new tv
right around the super bowl is the
second best time of year
to pick up a brand new television you're
going to find places
like best buy for example offering
really great deals on those brand new
and some slightly outdated tvs shopping
and trends expert sarah skurball says
new models will be released next month
so the retailers will be looking to make
some room for new inventory
all right even though tax day isn't
until mid april now is the time to find
deals on tax software that can help you
prep your finances or tackle
the taxes yourself consumers can find an
exclusive 35 percent off at h
r block from retailmenot and all this
month you can take advantage of special
promotions for dining at home
right now at home diners can find an
exclusive twenty five dollar off coupon
with the code
rmn five off for the new users
from postmates as well plus 10 cashback
the month of love brings savings to
encourage singles to put themselves out
there
find deals like 25 percent off your
subscription at match.com 15
off for new members at eharmony plug in
the code heart
one five and if you plan to order
flowers for valentine's one eight
hundred flowers has a 25
on an exclusive collection plug in the
code love
early denise